hey e braucht ihr was Antibiotika
diabetespillen
Hustenbonbons Wildkirsche ja schon
wieder sind hunderte Medikamente nicht
lieferbar genau wie letzten Herbst als
verzweifelte Eltern mit nölenden Kindern
von Apotheke zu Apotheke ranten weil es
keinen Fiebersaft mehr gab heute morgen
habe ich so einem süßen kleinen Mädchen
alle Packungen vor der Nase weggekauft
die Mutter hat sich tierisch aufgeregt
aber ich mag keinen Erwachsenen
Fiebersaft der schmeckt scheiße und
Lauterbach ermahnt uns nicht zu hamstern
danke für gar nichts selbst
Antibiotika und Blutdrucksenker sind
knapp e Lauterbach hast du eine blasse
Ahnung was passiert wenn ich meine
Blutdruck sein kann ich kriege dann
raste ich aus ich habe schon
Hausverbot in drei beschissenen
Apotheken